وتتولى المانيا قياده مناورات الدفاع
الجوي 23 التي تستمر حتى الثالث والعشرين
من يوليو حزيران الجاري يشارك في
المناورات نحو 250 طائره عسكريه متعدده
المهام والاغراض ابرزها الطائرات الحربيه
وطائرات التزود بالوقود جوا وطائرات
الانذار المبكر وتعود الطائرات ل 25 دوله
عضو في النيتو او حليفه من بينها اليابان
والسويد المرشحه للانضمام الى الحلف
مناورات الدفاع الجوي 23 ستضم نحو عشره
الاف فرد ينتمون لمختلف الوحدات الجويه
والبريه للنيتو وتهدف هذه المناورات الى
تعزيز التشغيل المشترك والحمايه من
المسيرات وصواريخ كروز في حال وقوع هجوم
على مدن او مطارات او موانئ واقعه ضمن
اراضي النيتو وتشمل المناورات تدريبا جويا
عمليا وتكتيكيا خصوصا في الم انيا وفي
تشيكا واستونيا ولاتفيا